[Amy] What??
[Mark] Just this hose, and the metal ones.
[laughter]
[Tyler] I got it!!
[Tyler, distorted] I got it!!
[Mark] That's good. That's good. That's good. That's good.
[Ethan] It's sad. It's sad. It's sad.
[Ethan] ... It's sad.
[laughter]
[Mark] It's our table!
[Ethan, laughing] Ah, I forgot.
[Mark] It's a classic!
[Mark] Yeeeah.
[Mark] Can't just let it go!
[Mark] It's so nice!
[Ethan] That's the first thing that comes to mind when I think of this table.
[Ethan] "Nice."
[Ethan] Yeah...
[Tyler] Yes.
[Ethan] That's what I [stutter] sad about.
[laughter]
[BEEP]
[Ethan] Tie-dye.
[Tyler] Multicolored.
[Mark] What??
[Mark] Alright, so, uh, welcome to...
[Mark] Markiplier Makes: Tie-Dye.
[Mark] I've never tie-dyed anything in my life.
[Tyler] Wait, really?
[Mark] Never, no.
[Tyler] Oh.
[Mark] I grew up poor.
[Mark] Like, we couldn't even afford shirts, let alone color the-- paint the shirts.
[Ethan] Every. Video.
[laughter]
[Ethan] "Guys. I was poor as a child."
[Ethan] "Not an ounce of food was put in my body."
[Mark laughing]
[Tyler] "I had to eat grass."
[Ethan] "We didn't even have grass. We didn't have a lawn!"
[Mark] If I had real nutrition I would have grown ten times your height!
[sad music]
[Mark] My potential was never reached sadly.
[Mark]  So we're gonna tie-dye just because I'm trying to relive all the childhood memories I never had.
[Mark] And those are the only reason we have ideas. So here's some instructions.
[paper crumpling]
[Mark] We don't need those!
[Ethan] No, we never...
[Tyler] Nah.
[Ethan] ... need instructions.
[Mark] We have friendship!
[Ethan] That's right!
[Tyler] That's the power of tie-dye it's made with
[Tyler, distorted] FRIENDS.
[Mark] Yeah, exactly.
[Ethan] You don't need instructions for anything...
[Ethan] ... as long as you have friends. Your friends will lead the way!
[Mark] Whoever makes tie-dye alone is sad and a loser, so...
[Mark laughing]
[Ethan] I'm changing my outfit!
[Mark] What the fuck?
[Ethan] And so, I. WILL.
[laughter]
[Tyler] I feel like... it got lower cut.
[Ethan] It's bigger pants this time.
[laughter]
[smack]
[Mark] But seriously.
[ominous music]
[Mark] Tie-dye is a dangerous thing. If you mix the wrong chemicals at the wrong times it will explode.
[Mark] Hence the gloves.
[Mark] Yeah. Gloves.
[Ethan] Do you want some gloves?
[Mark] I'd like some gloves.
[Mark wheezing]
[Tyler and Ethan laughing]
[Mark] ... Yes. Yes I--
[Mark moaning]
[Ethan] Don't stress yourself, alright?
[Mark] Ah, wait, the other one.
[Ethan] The other one, the other one...
[Mark] I need to feel complete.
[Ethan, muttering] Of course, of course...
[Mark moaning]
[Ethan] Put this on, we can't have any leakage.
[Mark] You're right, thank you.
[Ethan] There you go.
[Ethan] You wanna feel?
[Mark] I want to feel. Let me feel something.
[Ethan] Do you wan--
[Tyler] No.
[Mark] Lemme feel something.
[Ethan] Oh yes.
[Mark] Oh God...
[laughter]
[Ethan] I can't watch.
[Tyler] I was hoping--
[Mark] Close your fingers.
[Mark and Ethan grunting]
[Ethan] I've never felt a feeling such as this...
[Mark] Hang on, let me band you.
[Ethan, laughing] I like where this is going.
[laughter]
[Tyler] Why is it, every video...
[Tyler] ... you guys have to have some sort of GIF or clip that makes it super sexual.
[Ethan] No!
[Mark] Nooo!
[laughter]
[Mark] ... Nooo...! [laughing]
[Mark] Now that we've promised ourselves nerve damage in the near future...
[Mark] ... what we have here is the assembly of...???
[laughter]
[Ethan] I feel like a Power Ranger.
[Mark] Come on. Come on, do it. Come on. You won't.
[Ethan] Want me to punch you?
[Mark] Yeah.
[whiff]
[Mark] Go, I was ready.
[Ethan] You wa- You want a one-inch punch? [grunts]
[Ethan] How's it feel?!
[Mark] Like nothing.
[Mark] So as you could probably tell we can't do anything 'normally', ever, here?
[Ethan wheezes, pitched high]
[Mark] ... Do we have shirts? To tie--? Oh good.
[Ethan] Yes we do!
[laughter]
[Tyler] No! Your face.
[SLAM]
[Ethan] Oh...
[Tyler] Why?!
[Ethan] I didn't...
[Tyler] Every video, y--!!
[Ethan] Don't worry, I'll fix it!
[Mark] Amy spent so much time...
[Mark] ... assembling this perfectly. So...
[Mark] ... color coordinated.
[Tyler] No! No, no.
[Mark] Oh my God.
[Ethan] Oh no.
[Mark] So the reason we've got these all assembled nice like this is because...
[Mark] ... we're not just gonna do this normally, oh, no.
[Mark] We've got three shirts. We got three men.
[Mark] ........
[Mark] We got...?
[Mark] And we got tie-dye.
[Mark] So with this we're gonna make these shirts, but we're not gonna do it with our eyes.
[Mark] We're gonna do it with our souls.
[Mark] Like making love. You don't do it with your eyes!
[Mark] You don't do it with your body. You do it with your heart.
[Mark, whispering] And your soul.
[Tyler] You got a large soul.
[Mark, whispering] Thank you. I know.
[Mark] 'Bout time someone noticed.
[Ethan] You have a medium ...
[Ethan] ... penis.
[laughter]
[Mark] Chop.
[Ethan] Don't you dare put your fingers there.
[Mark] It's working.
[Ethan] It's working!
[Mark and Ethan] It's working!!
[Ethan] One... last...
[laughter]
[Mark] I love that you don't ask why!
[Ethan] Ohhh, you're making a balaclava?
[Mark] Yeah.
[Ethan] Yes!
[Mark] So.
[Ethan, laughing] Oh!
[Mark] As you can see...
[Mark] ... I cannot see.
[Mark] You want me to hold it again?
[Ethan] Yeah. No you've got--
[Mark, laughing] Okay, alright.
[Mark] Is it in front of me??
[Ethan] Hold on.
[Evan laughing]
[Ethan] Okay, go ahead.
[Mark] Okay, here we go.
[Ethan] You're gettin' there!
[Mark] I hope no fingies are in the way!
[Ethan] Oh you're close. You're so close Mark.
[Mark] Uh huh.
[Ethan] Cut with your soul!
[Mark] Oh, my soul...
[Ethan] Your soul!
[Mark] My large soul...
[Ethan] O-Oh there you go!
[Ethan] Ahh...
[Mark] Ahh...
[Mark] How'd I do?
[Amy laughing]
[Tyler] Is there a tag sticking out...?
[Mark laughing]
[Mark] Alright pussyfooting around.
[BOOM]
[Mark] We... are gonna tie-dye.
[Mark] And that means that we're gonna be tie dyeing these shirts...
[Mark] ... dry.
[Mark] We've all got our blindfolds on, right?
[Ethan] Uh-huh.
[Tyler] Yeah.
[Mark] Okay, we can't see a thing, right?
[Ethan, laughing] Right.
[Tyler] Where...?
[Mark] Cool. Everyone pick up their shirts...
[Tyler] I got it!
[Mark] Cool, okay. No peeking. No nothing.
[Mark] Yeah, there's a bucket of water.
[Tyler] Where's the bucket of water?
[Mark] On the-- As far away from you as possible.
[Mark] Just keep goin', man.
[Ethan] Probably close to it.
[Mark] Yeah, keep going.
[Mark] W-What are you doing, I can't see. Whaddya got?
[Tyler] I found a wall?
[Mark] Alright, that's not helpful.
[Tyler] I found a...
[Tyler] ... person!
[Evan laughing]
[Mark] Uh-huh, uh-huh. Talk us through.
[Tyler] Oh! I found a bucket!
[Mark] Alright, cool.
[Tyler] ... It's not a bucket.
[helicopter sounds]
[Tyler] I got it!!
[Mark] Alright, good job, man!
[Amy giggling]
[tap, tap, tap]
[Mark] Ohh...
[Tyler, startled] Ah, hi!
[Tyler] Here we go, we got it Mark.
[Mark] Alright, thanks man.
[Ethan wheezing]
[Mark] Alright, let's all raise our blindfolds like just for a little bit...
[Mark] ... so we got some preface here.
[Ethan coughing]
[Mark] Okay, cool. Alright. Good.
[Mark] Once we put 'em down then that's it.
[Mark] W-We'll call it, like, from there. BUT...
[Mark] ... Overall I don't know a lot of tie-dye techniques.
[Mark] We've got rubber bands here, it has something to do with the colors.
[Mark] But the most important thing is, when you grab a color...
[Mark] ... try to put it back in the same place you got it, 'cause--
[Tyler] 'kay.
[Mark] Everyone look at the colors, memorize this, because this is the only chance we get to look at this.
[Ethan] Okay.
[Ethan] Should we-- should we put the water up on the table first?
[Mark] Why??
[Ethan] Well, wait, we don't need the water.
[Mark] We're doing the DRY method.
[Ethan] That's right.
[Mark] Yeah, it's like a technique right, it'll help it run or something?
[Amy] Yeah, so it won't-- Yeah.
[Ethan] So if we want to use the water will have to navigate to it.
[Amy] Yeah.
[Mark] Yeah, yeah.
[Amy] Five? Seven?
[Mark] Seven? You want seven?
[Amy] Let's do seven.
[Mark] Le-Let's do seven, yeah.
[Amy] Seven? Alright.
[Mark] Seven sounds good.
[together] Three... two... one... Go.
[Mark] Huh? What?
[Tyler] Shhh.
[Mark] What?! Don't 'shhh' me!
[Ethan and Tyler] Shhh!
[Mark] Don't shush me!
[Ethan] I'm feeling those memories from camp flooding back to me.
[Mark] I'm feeling the memories of me living in a dumpster from age three to age four and a half.
[Mark] But time was hard to keep track of, people only threw out calendars every once in a while.
[Mark] I mean I had a block, I had blocks!
[Mark] I wasn't that poor, you know. They--
[Ethan] I thought you were The Most Poor.
[Mark] They threw out bricks from construction yards every once in a while, y'know.
[Ethan] Oh.
[Amy, laughing] There's nothing coming out, okay.
[Mark] Wha??
[Mark] Are you already on the dyeing phase?!
[Ethan] Yeah.
[Ethan] Oh.
[Mark] Oh, God!
[Tyler] Oh no.
[Amy] Just so you know.
[Mark] Oh, God!
[Mark gasping]
[Ethan] I 'squoozed' pretty hard.
[Mark] Okay, if you're trying to crush a baby's skull?
[Ethan] Not that hard.
[Mark] Y'know, that-- Not that hard?
[Ethan] Think of- think of trying to squeeze out a little bit of toothpaste.
[Amy] Yeah, Tyler's is comin' out.
[SQUELCH]
[Mark] AH! I felt splatter on me. Did it come out?
[Amy] It did!
[Tyler] Oh, I found the lid.
[Mark] Oh no, okay, all right, that's a good--
[Mark] That's a good benchmark. That's a good benchmark.
[Tyler] There's a big gap here, where'd this one go??
[Tyler] That's black... Unless you took black.
[Tyler] What're you looking for? That's--
[Tyler] Oh hi.
[Mark] Oh. Oh hi.
['Careless Whisper' plays]
[Ethan] I'm taking a chance.
[Mark] Uh-huh.
[Ethan] And I'm going to the ... water.
[Mark] The problem with tie-dye is it stains...
[Mark] ... REAL good.
[Mark] Staining is really the main fear...
[Sound byte] "Where am I??"
[Amy] Ethan's got three bottles that he didn't put back.
[Mark gasping]
[Wilhelm scream]
[thunk]
[Mark] Wha-?!
[Mark] I feel like there were a lot more bottles here before.
[organ/choir music]
[Ethan] Oh no. Oh no!
[Tyler] Red.
[Mark] I already GOT red.
[Ethan] Have my fingers leaked through?!
[Amy laughing]
[Ethan] Are my fingers through?!
[Mark] Huh??
[Ethan] Do I need new gloves?!
[Mark] No one's gonna tell you! How much time do we got?
[Amy] A minute twenty-five.
[Ethan gasping in fear]
[Mark] Okay, all right, that's all just a little. Just a, like a sweet dab.
[Mark] Sorry, I just touched you with my shirt.
[Ethan] Oh...
[Tyler] I need--
[Amy] You've got 30 seconds.
[Mark] Okay.
[Ethan] 30 seconds. I think mine's done. I don't know.
[Ethan] I did the water. I did the- I did some sploosh on it...
[Mark] I-I think I did everything I wanted to do.
[Ethan] What are you envisioning? Before we all bring up our blindfolds?
[Ethan] What are we envisioning that we have?
[Tyler] I think mine is a spider with multicolored legs.
[Ethan] Well, let's talk about colors first.
[Amy] Time's up!
[Ethan] Because I feel like...
[Ethan] ... other than the shape we could try and figure out the colors based on where we reached.
[Mark] Alright no one look yet.
[Ethan] I think I had some yellow??
[Tyler] Okay.
[Ethan] And a little bit of blue and a little bit of red.
[Tyler] I think I got...
[Tyler] ... red and blue and a purple. And I think I grabbed black at the end? But I hope not.
[Mark] I was trying to go for every color of the rainbow. I think.
[Mark] I thi-- [laughing]
[Mark] Shush!
[Mark] I was close! I don't think I--
[Mark] Oh I got a splash of green in there!
[Ethan laughs]
[Tyler] You got a nice yellow.
[Mark] I got a little green in there but not... not as much as I wanted.
[Ethan] I got kind of a cool tie-dye shirt!
[Ethan] Did you get the classic spiral?
[Mark] I don't know. I tried? Lemme see.
[Ooo's and aaah's]
[Ethan] That's kinda cool!
[Mark] That's not bad!
[Mark] It's not as colored as I would have liked it, but you know... Kind of like, it's got a minimalist feel to it.
[Tyler] Mine's a very white shirt with a lot of different...
[Mark] I like it 'cause you've got, like, stuff on the sleeves.
[Ethan] Yeah, I think me doing a lot of water maybe the spread happen.
[Mark] Yeah, but the spread's cool! You got a fully colored shirt.
[Mark] We'll come-- We'll be right back, when they're dry.
[Mark] In the meantime, here's a- a- a word from our sponsor.
[Ethan] I SAID GET READY TO COME (CUM?).
[Mark] Scene change!
[Mark] We're in a different place, but we got our shirts and our shirts are dry. Check them out.
[Mark] This is a shirt.
[Mark] That's a shirt. This is a shirt. So--
[Amy] Why aren't you spinning?
[Mark] Am I supposed to spin?
[Ethan] Yeah, you have to... rotisserize.
[Tyler] Show off your shirt.
[Mark] Why do I have to spin??
[Ethan] Well, to show the whole shirt!
[Tyler] Show the whole shirt, man.
[Ethan] Yeah!
[Tyler] Yeah.
[Tyler] That's good.
[Mark] Thank you.
[Ethan] Oh, yeah, it's- it's good.
[laughter]
[Mark] Alright, so let's judge them. Um...
[Mark] That one... it's not bad but it lost integrity of the shape it was in?
[Mark] Like, uh, I can't tell, like, if it was a spiral, if it was a circle out...
[Mark] That's the only thing I'll say about it. Plus the rubbings. Let me see the back.
[Mark] Yeah, that-- You got like a lot of rubbings back here.
[Ethan] It doesn't entirely look intentional.
[Tyler] I personally think Mark's is the best.
[Mark] You think that?
[Tyler] Yeah.
[Mark] You really think it?
[Mark] Yours sucks.
[Ethan, laughing] Yeah it just kinda looks like a kid threw up.
[Mark] No actually--
[Mark] I-I could see that like that being a mass-produced... like, just, design.
[Ethan] Th-There's too much green. It's bad.
[Evan speaks unintelligibly]
[Tyler] It's very green.
[Ethan] Yeah.
[Ethan] That's what happened when I dunked it in. It just all soaked up the color.
[Mark] Yeah, just too much water.
[Ethan] Mm-hmm
[Mark] Yeah, but not bad! Like, for my first tie-dye.
[Mark] I bet I wouldn't have been able to do something that looked good if I tried, and could see.
[Mark] 'Cause I literally just... it just happens to turn out this way, but it worked!
[Ethan] Yeah!
[Mark] I think the chaos is what made it really special.
[Mark] ... Okay.
[laughter]
[Ethan] I like the sleeve! I like that color a lot.
[Mark] Yeah no, that's good.
[Tyler] I like the...
[Mark] Yeah, your sleeves are on point.
[Mark] If you could, like, cut those sleeves off, put it on to just a plain white t-shirt, that actually might look really cool.
[Mark] It wouldn't be worth it. By any stretch of the imagination. But it'd look cool.
[Mark] Why'd you rub it, man?
[Tyler] 'Cause I... It was the way I thought to get more ink.
[Mark] ... Why'd you rub it.
[Ethan] Don't rub it.
[Mark] Don't rub it.
[Ethan] If you're at home... don't rub it.
[Mark] Hey. Stop rubbing.
[Amy laughs]
[Mark] Cut it out.
[Mark] Get some help.
Anyway, thank you so much for watching!
[Mark] Uh, this has been Wingus and Dingus.
[Mark] Dingus over here: CrankGamePlays.
[Mark] Wingus over here: Apocalypto_12 on Twitch.
[Mark] I have been Markiplier. Thank you so much for watching. Check out other cool stuff ...
[Mark] ... we've made in the description below and let us know of other ideas you have.
[Mark] Thanks again, and as always, we'll see you... in the next one.
[Mark] Buh-bye!
[Tyler] Bye!!
[Ethan] Tie-dye! Haha!
[Amy] I'm tryin' to spin-- I'm tryin' to spin into your spiral--!
[Mark, laughing] Oh!